Scotland
you're an Avenger
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
the trailer there's a line I don't have
to win but we both just have to lose you
must know when you say lines like that
that they're gonna end up in the trailer
like do you sort of know and when you're
saying those like one-liners do you have
to be careful not to like overdo it
under do it like what is the the key
yeah yeah there are those lines you
think all right this is a this line has
some real weight to it and um I always
feel like in those situations you as
really in any kind of situation you want
to do it lots of different ways so you
don't get into a rhythm and also it
gives an editor some options or the
director and then you hope they pick the
right one right yeah because they might
not
that's absolutely true yeah
um there's um there's a scene in this
movie
yeah I was getting Rocky Vibes yeah like
you were sort of like the little guy up
against yeah but this was a different
side than we've seen him before right so
how is it for you doing like a good
old-fashioned fight scene usually you're
Zippy and you're clever yeah and it is
kind of the case with I think a lot of
the Marvel movies just to have just and
certainly for Ant-Man to have just a an
all-out fight Kevin feige reminded me
today that the very first time we ever
see Ant-Man for going back to the very
first movie the very first shot is
Ant-Man getting punched in the face so
uh this seemed like it was kind of a
nice full circle I'm getting punched in
the face many many times it was great to
like go you sing all of this stuff
throughout the entire movie and
um shrinking and growing all all of that
and all these amazing effects that it
then we have a just a a fight and uh
yeah and doing that against Jonathan
Majors is
no walk in the park no yeah it's
intimidating he is uh he knows what he's
doing he was getting ready to go shoot
Creed after we filmed this so he was in
full fight mode and uh it was amazing I
mean it was challenging and that it that
a whole sequence took a long time to do
but it was uh it was great yeah Cassie
Lang or the actress Catherine has said
that you'd encouraged her to say the
joke like if you have a moment and you
want to say the joke say the joke like
just be feel free just do it was there
anybody if this was this pit if this was
paying it forward who is the person in
your career maybe that sort of
encouraged you to sort of get out there
do the one like say the joke improvise
that kind of thing oh gosh I don't you
know I've worked with so many
um great actors and and people that I've
learned from or just kind of watched and
uh yeah just I mean there's just so many
along the way it's tough to to really
just kind of like pick just one I I will
say
I got to work with Jack Nicholson and
Jack Nicholson
told me stuff little things that like
you can do
um and the other thing that he did that
it is still to this day just blows my
mind
he did all the stuff off camera for
doing a scene he was doing off camera
lines with me
and if it was on me he would
change things he would do stuff because
he knew what they might use and he knew
that if he did something some way he was
going to register in my eyes a certain
way
he is the he was the most giving
incredible actor to study and I think my
gosh Jack Nicholson I learned some
things from Jack Nicholson I don't know
how you get better than that
yeah it was amazing Paul writing Quantum
Mania that's what you get that's that's
how you get just as good if not now Jack
Nicholson said this if you're going to
climb a thousand versions of yourself up
a mountain
you gotta grab your hand
you gotta look
right in the eyes
[Music]
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life
where are you and Scott Lang as we start
this movie like because they have a date
night at the very beginning of this and
I love that she just seems at peace with
herself in this one like they're really
enjoying each other yeah if you sort of
break down how is the relationship going
because you at one point in some of the
other films they're just sort of getting
together you don't 100 ever know if she
really is into him yeah yeah no it was
so nice because we kind of did the
Moonlighting thing for a little while
where it was like well they won't they
and then even in the second film it was
like oh they clearly won't and they was
like oh hey baby they were
and this one is them definitively being
a couple
which is kind of the thing I've been
waiting for because if they're
definitively a couple who are in love
and are really taking care of one
another in real life then the moment
that the stakes go higher and the suits
go on it holds that much more potency
and gravitas when one or the other is in
trouble or one of the other needs
rescuing or one of the other is hurt and
um I think that's so fun to start there
to start with the peace and the beauty
and the love and the date and the
clinking beer bottles and then just
plunge them into the quantum realm and
and and let them you know
do what they're gonna do I love the Moon
Lighting reference because I remember
that show and that show was amazing yeah
and yeah do you think that
these two would have gotten together had
they just been like set up on a blind
date oh God no not in a million years
they wouldn't have when she first met
him she thought he was a bumbling fool
who was a waste of skin and it took a
lot of time for her to be convinced that
actually there was something worthwhile
in there oh my gosh it's so cute
um so I heard you say in another
interview that you were actually in
London shooting a lot of this Brie
Larson was shooting the Marvel yes and
that you sort of talked about how the
two of you had some really nice
conversations yeah and you referred to
Michelle as Mama Bear friend so can you
sort of talk about all that camaraderie
that was going on yes while you're away
shooting this film and I'm gonna add to
that okay Catherine Newton had become
part of the cast and so there was this
beautiful thing happening where
um I was forging a relationship with
Michelle which felt very supportive
mutually supportive and like really
intimate in a way that
I've never really been able to be with
my co-stars usually because often
they're men and there's just a certain
amount of intimacy that is reserved for
my man you know one man and it's like
you just have to walk that line very
carefully whereas with a woman you can
just plunge right in and you know in our
case we could and yeah
um and then with and then with Catherine
joining the first thing I did is reach
out to her and let her know I am here
for you I have your back whatever you
need if there's anything going on that
you're uncomfortable with you come to me
I will be your mama lion I will you know
I'm a Leo and I was like anything that
you need protection from or help with or
advice to get through like I'm here for
you and that that Dynamic of the three
for me was just an incredible big hug
after having spent two films just
surrounded by dudes you know they're
great dudes they're great dudes but it
was a very new Dynamic for me one that I
really appreciated and then Brie of
course was just on the lot nearby and I
would reach out to her sometimes and
she's like well how's it going over
there you know like what's your
experience I'd have like a really bad
day and be like is it any better over
there or like a great day and be like I
hope you're doing great and it was nice
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time so first of all I know you've said
in the past that Kang's evil his power
comes from great pain yeah in his past
what made him go to the dark side and
the evil because a lot of superheroes
Channel pain for the good for you as an
actor what made you go to that side what
made Kane go to that side uh for me you
know there's no uh
there's no scale of trauma or pain or
anything like that but but I think uh
there's what you think is a lot of pain
and a lot of suffering
um
as an individual and yeah you can turn
into a hero then and a pretty great hero
but what happens when you understand the
pain and suffering of not just your
lifetime but other lifetimes
and and if it's the only way to survive
you know is to try to correct it in some
way you know
yeah maybe that will maybe then you may
be labeled a bad guy that may be too
much you know
um to process you have to combat it
somehow you know and maybe that's how
you get a maybe that's how you get a
Kang I don't know what's his core
because I know he's play he's playing
different versions different you've
played him in Loki you played him in
this is there a core of King that you
return to yeah there's a uh uh there's a
DNA that that I think a king is and it's
uh it's early days but I'm I'm just
building it it's artistic you know I'm
just building it you know it's not in
the scripts or anything like that but
it's it's what is it that makes this
king of Kang you know so when I when
it's when it's ready to be talked about
I'll definitely
Fandango Fandango we are yes I'll come
to you in this film anyway there's a
balance there's some very quiet moments
yeah
and then there's the rage moments and
one of them's in the trailer and I know
you don't watch your own work but I know
I don't know if you've seen that and the
eyes are glowing for you as an actor
when you're expressing yourself like
that those rage moments is it cathartic
what does it feel like for you uh it
feels like rage you know it feels like
rage it feels like oh you've gotten to a
point where you you're getting something
out you know you can have emotion it's
when you express the actor's job and and
our jobs as human beings is when we
express the emotion that's when you
either get things done or get in trouble
you know what I mean and it's how you do
it and when you decide to do it and so
you I rarely get to a point where I can
express
that yeah that type of rage you really
get to a point in life where you feel
that or can express that
so yeah it's uh it's an exploration you
know and it's taxing you know you're
adrenalized at the end of it but then
you realize on the way home wow I'm
exhausted yeah yeah because you just
took your engine from zero to 180 you
know multiple times that day I know
there's a Star Wars there's a lot of
Star Wars references and I did get a
Darth Vader moment for one second when I
saw you was there any sort of channeling
of that any conversations with Peyton
this is the like this is the first time
I guess after last night that the Star
Wars stuff came up I was like Star Wars
what
what oh where is that from like maybe I
don't know the maybe I don't know it
well enough to know to to
feel and recognize the references but no
there was no stuff I didn't watch any
movies you know and or nothing like that
you know I was like this is I watch Star
Wars movie Hannibal Lecter because I got
that what you got the feeling is the
archetype potentially is the archetype
of like a pure villain or a pure
sociopath like you're that's what we all
recognize that and those
they're so iconic because they're so
pure like have electric Darth Vader oh
Genghis Khan any of those guys like
that's a very clear energy you know and
so I mean that's a huge compliment if
someone is feeling those type of energy
from uh from Ken because I was
definitely the intention people still
need help that that's why we made this
[Music]
for deep space but Kawana so first of
all I want to talk a little bit
Cassie and the fact that she has seen
like you've said a giant bug in her room
when she's six how has this affected her
like as we're meeting up at this age how
is everything that has shaped her
affected her because we kind of assume
she's going to be like a normal teen and
she's not I don't think you can be
normal I mean first of all nobody's
normal I'm proof of that but I think
that she grew up with a superhero Dad
she grew up you know and then she's got
superhero kind of has superhero
grandparents Hank and Janet and then a
stepmom who's a superhero so I think
she's just got good inspo you know
they're surrounding her and kind of
showing her the ropes and then her dad's
gone for a long time
um and I think that changes somebody I
think it's inevitable that she's going
to be different um and when I kind of
connected to was this idea of seizing
seizing the moment not she wasn't gonna
let anything go she missed a lot of time
with her dad so she she knows the value
of every moment so she leads with her
heart and she doesn't think too much
about it she just jumps what I loved
about is there was moments where you
guys were sort of comparing notes like
oh this is the move oh do you crave this
when you're like super heroing and doing
that kind of thing but what do you think
sets her apart from her dad and which
ways is she different from her dad in
terms of like her power the power she
feels and sort of her skills I think she
um she's she's a little more open-minded
I don't think she has the experience he
has to have helped him become the hero
that he is I think she's she lacks the
the knowledge and the wisdom so
She's Not Afraid that's the biggest
thing she's not scared of anything
I think you should be a little just
aware of the the repercussions of your
actions and she's not she's fearless
she's impatient and uh she's kind of a
mess so that's the difference
um but the similarity is they're both
just like everyone they're just regular
people there's always like a moment in
Marvel film where there's a one-liner
and one-liners are the stuff of Legends
and I really think the line it's never
too late to be a CS is going to become
iconic thank you so how do you think I
hope so how is it sort of shooting that
on the day did you say it a million
times because you sort of know when
you're saying lines like that I set it
to a little Mark on the ground and I
felt the excitement around the line I
think it's such a brilliant script Jeff
loveness like just perfected Cassie in
my opinion I was like this is written
for me but I definitely thought about it
I definitely wanted it to be perfect so
I hope I hope it was I know Paul Rudd um
you said he encouraged you to say the
joke like say the joke improvise yeah
have fun and do things and sort of give
you that yes what was a a line that that
made it in or a moment that made it in
that was sort of like your moment that
you kind of that you could there's a
moment when I'm I first try to be a
superhero and I like clumsily fall and
then I'm like okay I have a suit you
know and I like pose that was improv and
uh there's other things like I saw it
the second time last night and I
realized a lot of it was improv and then
a lot of it wasn't the real key though
to improv is that it creates an energy
it makes you laugh it keeps it fresh so
even if you don't use any of it because
we always said the script we always said
the lines on the page maybe added
something at the beginning or the end
but we always said the words
um it just adds an energy and I think
audiences can connect to that and Paul
Rudd that was great advice don't hold
back take the risk fail do the thing
that's not funny because at least um you
can say that you went home and did
everything you did and this was an
opportunity that I didn't take for
granted and I loved making this movie I
loved making a fool of myself and it's
because I trusted Paul and I trusted our
director Peyton they believed did me so
I said okay real quick moving forward
what are you most excited about I know
we don't know where she's going but
based on the comics is there sort of
like a comic book reference or a
character that you would love to sort of
meet up with whether maybe it's a past
MCU character or one that we haven't
seen yet oh geez that's so difficult
um I'd love to meet Groot
wouldn't that be cool
or um nebula
I feel like nebula and her would like
connect
I know she was an athlete in one of the
comics I think she should play golf in
another one oh my gosh now now I'm
waiting usually there's golf I get golf
in every project I'm in somehow like I
use a club as a weapon I'm playing mini
golf there's no golf in this one it's a
secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you not a
spoiler question where's their
relationship as we pick up in this movie
how have they made up for lost time
what's their Facebook Facebook
relationship status have they been
having date night where are these two
when the movie starts
well I think for Janet you know having
spent 30 years in the quantum realm and
and thinking at at some point she was
never going to get out and then
reuniting with
with her husband and her daughter it's
she's just just savoring this this time
and um and I think you know they're just
um spending every moment together and
um kind of retired really that's sort of
the feeling that I get
um and you know but Janet has has
secrets and I think I think there was a
lot
down there that um
haunts her
and so there's um you know as Secrets do
there's a bit of a a a separation and a
guardedness about her that I think the
family senses and as it is revealed over
time each of them have had other perhaps
romances it has been 30 years a little
bit of jealousy people have needs people
have needs people have needs yeah I
don't think we thought about it a whole
lot where it was again the secretly and
and said word once you got back together
again we were talking about it recently
I don't know how long when the movie
started maybe four years that's living
back together again and the thing it
definitely worth making up for lost time
in terms of domicility and
we start off with a whole pizza family
night at home and keeping that whole
sense of like you're pretty close and
and comfortable
and probably better for things to go
unsaid you know as far as
huge memory every time I think about 30
years why does it make it 10 years and
aren't we
and Austin in this way by three in this
one that's what I just popped poppy yeah
yeah this one because that was the first
one
I don't think it's
paid I have questions written and then
when I saw the film last night I rewrote
them all because one thing I didn't
expect was that you're you're
essentially leading this film for a
great part of it there's a lot of
physical action that you were called on
to do some fighting and that kind of
thing were you chomping at the bit after
the last few to sort of dive into sort
of more of a lead because it was just so
thrilling to see oh thank you
um well you know you're always excited
to get more to do like well maybe not
always but um I was I was excited
because when when when Peyton had
approached me
um
I didn't really know who Janet Van Dyne
was and she was actually the founding
member of the Avengers and she was she's
like a real seminal character in the
Marvel world and he said I want to bring
her to life and I thought wow that's
really an honor and that's super
exciting and
um didn't get a chance to really do that
in the last one so it was it was it was
nice to to show her some of her
background and and
um you know that she was a real freedom
fighter and
um and uh you know how and and her and
her brilliance
um is it just me or it seemed like
the Marvel one-liners are stuff of
Legends and it seemed like you were just
eating it up my audience erupted when
you had your moment on the bridge there
was two raptures applauses during the
screening and that was one of them
um just for you those Marvel one-liners
they can be tricky but it seemed like is
it me or were you just enjoying the heck
out of it well I was I mean yeah it's
always fun to have something to do and
in this case I was not going to be
leading the action by any means so it
was nice to have a couple of Woody spots
but you're really good at that oh yeah
every time every time
every time but it was a wonderful
opportunity again you know a nice group
of Joy working with uh with all of them
and yeah it's nice to have I was very
happy to uh to come together with my
aunts if somebody had told you 40 years
ago there's going to be a scene with a
spaceship and you're gonna be steering
it with it in a weird what would you
have said probably what I said when I
saw the whole thing for real I said you
got to be out of your mind that was a
look on your face you said
you mean
put my hands
this is where's the joke I'm missing the
joke where you know where is the thing
and I thought I thought somebody was
messing with me I thought maybe this is
some kind of setup you know from candid
camera or something like that let me put
these things moving around and putting
them all in but that's the thing with
this world you can do you can do
anything the absurdity is
exactly yeah it's like how absurd can we
be and get away with it it must I was
wondering like what it would actually
look like for the two of you on the day
if
some screen and you're standing on
whatever and it's moving how absurd is
it it's pretty absurd
yeah yeah it could be yeah I mean it
depends especially
wasn't so much the ground was there the
the the the the ground was all real
but it was the thing when they added all
those floating little insects and stuff
going around we would have to hold your
hands up you know and there's going to
be something eventually but there you go
a little higher so that's good and
higher right and then you this and then
you look at it you look at that oh my
God looks like I'm actually holding
something yeah I couldn't get over that
Beyond
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
you've talked in the past about how
Ant-Man has been a palette cleanser but
in this case you're kicking off phase
five so what are the ingredients that
were important to you did you have any
conversations with Kevin because I felt
watching it that someone gave you the
keys to the kingdom and said make the
movie you want to make that it felt like
it was a freedom in that there was and I
it's it's kind of one of the things I've
always loved about Ant-Man is when we
started with the first one
there was freedom on that because we
were kind of operating in the margins
right he wasn't a full-fledged Avenger
at all and you know he wasn't a super
scientist and like you know we it was
still a question in 2014-15 is the
audience gonna accept a superhero called
Ant-Man who shrinks and talks to ants or
they can accept Paul Rudd as a superhero
and all these years later fortunately
for us you know they have accepted this
character and so now by the time we we
had introduced the quantum realm we got
to make a third Ant-Man movie which is
insane uh but if we were gonna do it I
really wanted to show the audience
something different like the worst sin
you can commit is to to board audience
and to do the same thing so we had the
answer in our hands it was like I want
to know what what was Jana Van Dyne
doing with those 30 years in the quantum
realm she must have had a full life and
maybe this is also a great way to
introduce kangna Cocker into the MCU uh
so to get a chance to sort of design
this entire environment and put together
a symbolless crew of crazy artists and
come up with as many whacked out science
fiction Concepts as we could uh I I
loved it where does broccoli man come
from
we had our artists draw like just draw
your top 10 weird characters that you
might see in their Quantum realm we were
going through reams of these things and
oh this is cool this Blobby guy if you
could make a photo real version of that
that might be interesting and this is
and then there was this one guy that
like what is this guy he looks like
broccoli and he wasn't he had these
stalks and eyes but he was a Broccoli
Guy and then it it struck Jeff loveness
the writer and me it's funny it's like
well Hank Pym would look at that guy and
just say holy that guy looks like
broccoli just like call it as he sees it
and that seemed acceptable in this movie
it was like yeah that's funny let's put
this in the movie I like it I asked
Jonathan and he was shocked that I said
I had a Darth Vader moment watching him
obviously there's some Star Wars
references in this film some callbacks
um if you can just speak to that a
little bit I'm so I know you're not
surprised to hear me say that well
listen I we all grew up with Star Wars
Star Wars is uh it's our generation's
mythology
um and I've worked in the Star Wars
world I love it but I like the idea of
doing something here that like maybe
took a dash of Star Wars but also some
Flash Gordon and some heavy metal
magazine from the 70s or 80s and a
little bit of uh Flesh Gordon the
x-rated rip off of Flash Gordon and
Barbarella and Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy and all these influences that I
grew up with and loved and just make it
weird and then you send our heroes down
there and suddenly Ant-Man the WASP were
the least weird characters in this
environment it just that seemed fun but
Star Wars is resonant just because
George Lucas you know decades ago now
created such a vivid world right and
that's what has stuck with people this
how specific it is
so we didn't want to copy or design
anything remotely like Star Wars but we
wanted to have that specificity to this
thing and we wanted to like
take you to a place where it's like oh
we've we have an idea of kind of how the
ecosystem works or how people respond or
what the laws of physics are in this
place it's weird and it's different but
we've we've thought about it